[Music]
we have been trying to get steven
weinberg to the festival for a number of
years and it's a it's a big trip from
from Austin to come to New York for the
festival so we needed to do something
special and we thought about it and we
realized that as many of you know the
typical program at the World Science
Festival is one in which we have a
number of people leading scientists
leading thinkers artists on stage
discussing various topics at the
forefront of ideas forefront of science
but we have never had a program where a
single individual takes a stage and
speaks about something that they
consider a vital importance
so we decided to inaugurate a new
lecture series so once each festival
we're going to have a preeminent
scientist who will come and speak on
something that they consider critical
for the general public to have some
insight into and it is our great
pleasure that the inaugural lecture is
indeed going to be given by Steven
Weinberg so as many of you yes please
so as many of you know steven weinberg
is the Joji welch professor of science
at the university of texas austin he's a
member of the physics and astronomy
departments numerous awards accolades
National Medal of Science and of course
the Nobel Prize in Physics in 1979 which
was awarded for his insights which
basically took the first major step
toward what Einstein called the unified
theory a theory that would perhaps
describe all of nature's forces in one
single package the previous step was
taken by Maxwell in the late 1800s
Stephen Weinberg who shared the prize
with Salam and glasha took the next step
giving us the electroweak theory for
which he was awarded the Nobel Prize now
all of that I think is well known to you
and I think it captures well the stature
of the individual who'll be addressing
us here this afternoon but I worked at
IBM as a summer student in the 1980s
sort of to make money for college kind
of thing and the person who I worked for
there his name was John Kok and eminent
computer scientist and when I a couple
years later told him that I was invited
to give a talk at UT Austin on some work
that I'd done in string theory and that
Steven Weinberg would be there he took
me to the side he said you should know
there are Nobel laureates
and then there are Nobel laureates
Steven Weinberg is a Nobel laureate and
indeed he is the preeminent theoretical
physicists in the world today and it
gives me a great pleasure a great honor
to give you now professor Steven
Weinberg
thanks Brian look
Thank You Ryan I feel very honored to
inaugurate what I think will be a great
series of lectures under the heading of
on the soaked shoulders of giants in
this wonderful festival in years to come
I also feel very honored that you showed
up here on such a beautiful day when it
would be so nice to be outside and sit
and play a game of chess or something in
Washington Square so thank you it is
this year we are celebrating we in
physics are celebrating an anniversary
it is just 100 years since Ernest
Rutherford in his laboratory at the
University of Manchester announced the
discovery of the nucleus of the atom
in the experiment in his laboratory a
beam of charged particles called alpha
particles that are produced by the
natural radioactivity of radium was
allowed to fall on a very thin gold foil
and to Rutherford's great surprise that
was found that some of these alpha
particles were bouncing backwards and
Rutherford concluded from this that the
alpha particles must be encountering
something inside the gold atom something
very small and very heavy having most of
the mass of the atom and this he
identified as the nucleus of the atom it
was the beginning of modern atomic and
nuclear physics now this was great
science unquestionably but it wasn't
what I would call big science
Rutherford's experimental team consisted
of one postdoc named Geiger you may know
the name and an undergraduate and that
was it the he was supported by a grant
from the Royal Society of London of 70
pounds it's true money was worth more
than but still 70 pounds the most
expensive part of his experimental setup
was the sample of radium radium was then
very expensive and but he didn't have to
pay for it he borrowed it from the
Austrian Academy of Sciences but
experimental science soon got much
bigger the alpha particles these
energetic charged particles from radium
decay didn't have enough energy to
actually get inside the nucleus of the
gold atom the repulsive force was too
great they couldn't break through that
electrical repulsion in order to break
into the nucleus and see what it it's
made of it was necessary to use
particles whether alpha particles or
other charged particles that were not
coming from natural radioactivity but
were artificially accelerated to higher
energy and in the 1930s a variety of
accelerators were invented for this
purpose of first perhaps the most famous
is the cyclotron invented by Lawrence
and they got bigger maurice goldhaber
who for many years was director of
Brookhaven laboratory and alas died a
few weeks ago once recalled that he had
seen a photo of Rutherford sitting with
his apparatus in his lap and then he saw
a later photograph of a number of
nuclear physicists sitting in the lap of
a cyclotron this work and building
accelerators was taken up again
after World War two and now with a new
purpose the work continued on studying
the nucleus using particles to get
inside and break it up and see what's
going on there but now there was a new
purpose to create new forms of matter
this had already started in the 30s with
the discovery of a variety of new
particles that don't exist in everyday
life that were found in cosmic rays
cosmic rays are extremely energetic
charged particles that strike the Earth
from outer space and produce reactions
in the upper atmosphere in which new new
forms of matter are created the cosmic
rays themselves are nothing special
their nuclei of various atoms hydrogen
helium and so on but they have so much
energy what that when they hit oxygen
and nitrogen atoms in the upper
atmosphere they produce new things the
first of these new things was called the
positron it's the antiparticle of the
electron a particle just the same as an
electron but with positive rather than
negative charge and then other particles
were discovered I would need and burden
you with them called mesons and
hyperness about a dozen or so new
particles and when I was a graduate
student in the 1950s I had to learn a
lot about cosmic ray physics because
that's where all the information was
coming from about new particles and I
remember how surprised I was when a
professor at Princeton where I was a
student
Arthur Whiteman told me that pretty soon
physicists would no longer being be
worried about cosmic rays they would be
getting the information about particles
from new kinds of accelerators which
would accelerate known particles like
protons which are the nuclei of hydrogen
atoms or alpha particles to very high
energy
where they would collide with each other
or with stationary targets and in that
collision new matter would be formed I'm
going to mention just one equation in
this talk but it's an equation I think
you've all heard equals MC square the
energy required when you have a
collision of a number of particles the
energy you have to have in that
collision to produce a new kind of
particle with a mass M is the mass M
times the square of the speed of light
and the bigger the mass the more energy
you need now the reason for switching
from cosmic rays to artificial
accelerators is not the cosmic rays
didn't have enough energy they have
plenty of energy but they're
unpredictable you never know when a
cosmic ray is going to hit your
apparatus or hidden atom in the upper
atmosphere and do something interesting
whereas with an accelerator you know
exactly what particles are hitting your
apparatus and when they're coming in and
you can do controlled experiments but
for this purpose accelerators had to get
even bigger they the way that the
accelerator accelerates the particles is
the particles are sent around a ring and
every time they go round a little extra
energy is given to them until they get
up to the energy you want now they're
kept going around the ring by strong
magnetic fields which in which the
product the charged particles paths are
curved but there's a limit to how strong
you can make magnets and so in order to
accelerate particles to very high energy
you have to reduce the curvature of
their path so it doesn't need such a
strong magnetic field to keep curving
them and that means you have to make the
path bigger and they did get bigger when
I went out to Berkeley in the late 1950s
Berkeley had what was then when it was
built the largest accelerator in the
world it was called the bevatron and
unoccupied
the whole of a large building up there
in the Berkeley Hills where the
radiation laboratory was it was built
specifically to create a particular new
particle called the antiproton the
antiparticle of the proton which is the
nucleus of the simplest element hydrogen
and sure enough the antiproton was
discovered as on schedule but no
surprise but what wasn't expected was
that uh a whole slew in fact hundreds of
new particles were discovered so many
that theorists began to wonder do we
really even know what we mean by an
elementary particle if there are
hundreds worth a thousand of them how
could they be elementary it was a very
confusing time but also a very exciting
time and I remember though that a little
bit later the an atmosphere of gloom
excuse me
settled on Berkeley when they realized
that to go up to even higher energy the
next generation of accelerators would be
much too large to fit into the Berkeley
Hills the next generation were
accelerators being built at Stanford and
Fermilab outside Chicago and CERN in
Europe they couldn't fit into Berkeley
and they got pretty big the large
accelerator at Fermilab is a ring four
miles in circumference no longer
something that can fit into a building
but rather a feature of the landscape
which you can see from space and in this
ring reproducing the Illinois Prairie as
it was before white before Europeans
came they have a herd of bison grazing
right now we're waiting for
new results from a even bigger
accelerator at in Europe called the
Large Hadron Collider now I should
explain that the purpose of building
bigger and bigger accelerators is not
really ultimately to collect new kinds
of particle and list them in an album as
if you're collecting stamps or orchids
the purpose is by creating kinds of
matter which because it's they're heavy
and unstable don't exist in ordinary
matter you're filling out the picture of
the the way nature is and you're being
led toward a set of laws of nature
physical principles that govern why
everything is the way it is in other
words it what we were after in building
these large accelerators was not
particles but principles by the
mid-1970s
this theoretical progress had been made
quite a lot we had developed what is
called now the standard model of
elementary particles it's a theory that
works it describes virtually all the
particles in nature and virtually all
the forces in nature certainly
everything we can study in existing
accelerator laboratories has been
thoroughly well tested but it's
certainly not the end of the story so
for one thing in the standard model
there is a somewhat mysterious list of
particles that appear in this theory as
elementary particles among them are
quarks two kinds of quarks the lightest
ones make up the protons and neutrons
which in turn make up atomic nuclei
three quarks in each proton or each
Neutron but there are altogether six
types of quarks the other four are heavy
and unstable they're all equally
important as far as the standard model
is concerned it's just an accident that
two of them are the ones that appear in
ordinary matter there are other
particles there's the electron and it
has a couple of siblings which are just
like the electron but heavier and also
unstable now we have a table based on
experimental data of the properties of
these particles their masses especially
and we know what their masses are but we
don't know why they are we've been
looking at this table of experimental
information about these masses now for
several decades with the feeling that
it's got to be telling us something and
we don't know what it's telling us it's
a little bit like having a manuscript in
a say linear a a language that hasn't
been deciphered you feel you ought to
know what it's saying but you don't know
what it's saying another thing
astronomers tell us that 5/6 of the
matter of the universe it is some kind
of dark matter which was discussed
already in a panel in this festival this
dark matter none of the particles of the
standard model have the right properties
to make up the dark matter
so 5/6 of the mass of the universe is
not in the form of anything described by
the standard model
well something we ought to know more
about
and finally there's a little technical
detail that gravity doesn't fit in the
standard model it's also something we
would like to know that more about so we
have to hope for more insight from the
next generation of experiments at big
accelerators like the one that I
mentioned before at the Large Hadron
Collider in Europe now that is pretty
big at 17 miles in circumference it's
not visible from space because it's
buried in a tunnel which goes across the
border between France and Switzerland in
this accelerator two beams of protons
are going round and round kept in their
orbits by powerful magnets the magnets
have a strength Oh roughly 10,000 times
the strength of the Earth's magnetic
field which acts on compass needles when
the Large Hadron Collider gets up to its
final design capability it will
accelerate particles to an energy which
is about 7,000 times the energy
contained in the mass of a hydrogen atom
it's an energy which is about a million
times the energy of the alpha particles
in Rutherford's famous experiment it is
certainly big science it's also big
science in another sense a human sense
which is not so good the experiment one
experimental team at the Large Hadron
Collider that I happen to look up for
this talk
the Atlas collaboration has over a
thousand PhD physicists working together
they'll all sign the research articles
when they come out the title page will
be much larger than the rest of the
article
and the I don't know how a young
experimental physicist can make a name
for himself or herself working in a
collaboration like this also the
experiments from planning to completion
take over a decade which is a fair
fraction of a scientist working career
and it may be an experiment which turns
out to yield nothing exciting so I just
think heavens everyday that I'm a
theorist I don't have to do that but
we're forced into the mold of big
science by the logic of the subject at
any one moment the particles that we
know about are those that have a low
enough mass so that they can be created
at existing accelerators and if you want
to find new forms of matter to fill out
our picture of the way the world is
governed then you have to have higher
energy and we can't help it the purpose
is not to get records for the number of
particles or the energy it's to learn
about the laws of nature now
we there's one particle in particular
that we expect without certainty to
prove produced at the Large Hadron
Collider it's a particle called the
Higgs boson it is predicted as a
necessary feature of nature by a theory
that unifies the weak and
electromagnetic forces that Brian
mentioned Dennis kind introduction
in this theory I should explain the weak
nuclear forces are forces that act
inside the atomic nucleus allowing
neutrons to turn into protons or protons
to turn into neutrons they're very
short-range and hence they only act
inside the nucleus the electromagnetic
forces you all
know about that light that's staring me
in the eyes is an electromagnetic wave
and we've all felt that the force of
magnets pulling on a piece of iron they
seem very different but in the equations
of the theory they are treated the same
way also in the equations of the
standard model these the particles the
that I mentioned earlier the quarks and
the electrons and so on have zero mass
yet obviously that's not the way nature
is when you have as a situation where
you have equations with certain very
great simplicity a great degree of
symmetry a symmetry between the weak and
electromagnetic forces for instance a
simplicity that says all the masses are
zero and yet that's not realized in the
solutions of the equations which
describe what actually we see in nature
how does the solutions not respect the
symmetry of the equations well they're
various ideas the simplest idea which
appeared in the original version of this
theory invokes a new set of fields in
addition to the electromagnetic field
that all the other fields of the
standard model a new set of fields which
pervade the universe one of which is met
would be manifested as an actual
physical particle electrically neutral
heavy unstable which has come to be
called the Higgs boson and this particle
if it exists will be found at the Large
Hadron Collider as we know enough about
it to know that its properties make it
findable it may not exist there are
alternative theories there's a theory
called Technicolor theory which
dispenses with these element with these
fields and does not predict the Higgs
boson but prediction said a whole slew
of other particles one of which may
recently have been seen at Fermilab
although it's too early to tell a
particle called a technolon and we don't
know what the LHC was is gonna find if
we did know we didn't wouldn't have to
build it
but we do know as actually a
mathematical theorem based on what we've
already learned that either one or the
other of these new kinds of particles
will be found at the Large Hadron
Collider
it will settle the question of how
particles get masses and how they how
the symmetries get broken now
we're but I would guess that experiments
that the Large Hadron Collider are not
going to take us all the way to what we
want what we want is a set of
fundamental principles of great
simplicity compelling quality which will
tell us why the world is the way it is I
don't think we're going to get there
from just what we learn at the Large
Hadron Collider so inevitably physicists
are going to be going back to
governments and asking again for money
to build the next large accelerator
which most of us think would probably be
an accelerator which instead of
accelerating protons round and round a
ring will accelerate electrons and their
antiparticles positrons in a straight
line so that they collide with each
other and all the energy and the head-on
collision is available for producing new
forms of matter because you can do it
precise experiments with this kind of
accelerator that you can't do with the
Large Hadron Collider but it's gonna be
a tough sell and I'm worried about
whether or not we're going to succeed in
fact I'm worried that this heroic period
of breaking into first breaking into the
nucleus and then creating new forms of
matter and developing a standard model
I'm worried that this is going to come
to an end in our lifetime well maybe
your lifetime and my pessimism comes
partly from my experience with another
large accelerator project which was
cancelled by a vote in the House of
Representatives in 1993
this was an accelerator called the
superconducting supercollider
and I'm going to abbreviate that to SSC
the SSC would have been even bigger than
the Large Hadron Collider a 53 mile
circumference and would it if it would
have accelerated particles to 3 times
the energy that can be reached at the
LHC and it would already have answered
these questions that were hoping to see
answered by the LHC it we struggled to
get it funded it about a billion dollars
was spent on it and then it was killed
as I said by a vote in the House of
Representatives one thing I learned
during the fight to get the SSC built
was that no scientific discovery is
remotely as important to a legislature
as the economic interests of his or her
own constituents and this is not
something evil this is the the way
democracy is supposed to work
legislators is supposed to represent the
interests of their constituents the
problem is that it all too often turns
out to be the short-term interests and
they don't provide enough wisdom and
guidance so that their constituents will
respond to the long-term needs not only
of their own little district but of
society in general a an accelerator a
big scientific laboratory in fact of any
full kind is among other things a public
works program which provides jobs for
local people and ISM provides purchasing
of local products and generally speaking
the legislature from any district where
a big project like this is going to be
located will be enthusiastic about it
and every other legislature will look at
it with either indifference or
Stila tea I remember that when I was
testifying in favor of the SSC before
the site was chosen the site chosen was
in Texas before that site was chosen a
senator responded to something I had
said and said you realize young man that
right now there are a hundred senators
in favor of this project but once the
site is chosen that number will drop to
two and he wasn't far wrong
for an example actually referring to the
house rather than the Senate at one
point there was a member of the House of
Representatives now retired Sherwood
Bullard from upstate New York who was
enthusiastic supporter of the SSC and
there was a site in upstate New York
that was one of the candidate sites for
the location of the SSC it was a bizarre
sight it was in the Adirondack Mountains
so isolated that the nearest large
Airport was Montreal and but very early
in the process this site was dropped and
was clear it would not be on the short
list of candidate sites that would go to
the Secretary of Energy and bollard then
turned 180 degrees and became an active
and very effective opponent of the SSC
project when the site was announced as a
Texas site many politicians and
journalists began to call it a Texas
pork project it really wasn't I was on
the site selection committee and we
operate in an entirely non-political way
and identified two sites that we thought
were the best sites in the country one
of them was a Texas site
the other was a site in Illinois near
Fermilab they both had advantages the
Texas site one I think because it had
better geology and more enthusiastic
support
from the local inhabitants but you
couldn't contradict the press who kept
calling it Texas pork one congressman
from the district where it was to be
built Joe Barton who's still an
influential member of the House of
Representatives was a an enthusiastic
supporter of the SSC and then when a
vote in Congress killed it he turned
against not only the particle physics
but high in it but physics in general I
think and he tried to prevent the
funding of American participation in the
LHC fortunately without success
international that was a case where we
were talking about national
collaborations international
collaborations are that much harder
we've seen an example of this recently
there's a thermal nuclear power
laboratory a very large project called
it tear international thermonuclear
experimental reactor and the project was
almost canceled because of a conflict
whether it would be located in France or
in Japan and this may be the greatest
obstacle to getting the thing built but
there are other obstacles science
funding has generally decreased not just
building accelerators for example the
National Science Foundation a decade ago
granted a third of all grant proposals
for research in in science of all kinds
and now they grant only a little over
twenty percent of those grant proposals
but the trouble is as you cut down
funding for science you can't really
reduce the funding for an accelerator
mit doesn't work to build half an
accelerator the particles have to go all
the way around
and it also doesn't help to build little
little accelerators because they're
cheaper because that would only give you
things you already knew about so there's
no alternative to spending a lot of
money if you want to advance our
knowledge of nature at its deepest level
and this has led unfortunately to a
degree of competition within the
scientific community there are
scientists who don't work in elementary
particle physics and who feel that the
money being spent on expensive things
like accelerators wouldn't be much
better spent in other fields of science
as for example their own fields and in
in particular the one of the things that
hurt the SSC effort was the opposition
of a solid-state physicist the physicist
who studies the properties of solids who
at that time was president-elect of the
American Physical Society and therefore
had a degree of influence he wouldn't
otherwise have had in making the
argument for this kind of spending on
big science we're hampered by the fact
that in the short run we can't point to
practical technologies that are going to
come out of the discoveries we make
where elementary particle physics will
not in a foreseeable way produce useful
things like lasers or transistors which
are the product of research for example
in the physics of the solid state so we
have to answer why should society
provide funds for these big projects big
accelerators I think the answer has to
be and this is certainly the answer for
me a vision of the way the world is
ordered the properties of ordinary
matter the things we're made of the
things we use in our everyday life are
what they are because of the principles
governing
electrons and atomic nuclei and light
and other kinds of electromagnetism and
their interactions with each other and
we now know that those properties of
atomic nuclei and electrons and so on
are what they are because of the
principles of the standard model from
which they can be derived where do the
principles of the standard model come
firm and how do we join that with other
things that are not contained within the
standard model like gravity what we
don't know and that's we we want to make
the next step toward a really unified
view of nature and it's a tragedy to
imagine that this is going to come to an
end in our own time not everyone feels
that this kind of fundamental science is
of importance I remember I was on a
radio show at the time we were arguing
over the super collider and there was a
congressman I had took the opposite view
and he said he's not against science
he's not even necessarily against big
science he just thinks we have to set
priorities I said well I quite agree
now experiments at the super collider
the SSC are going to help us discover
the laws of nature the principles
governing everything wouldn't you think
that would earn a high priority
I remember precisely what he said word
for word this was just one word he said
No
what can you do how do you make a case
for someone who doesn't already feel the
importance of what you're doing well I
think the least important argument we
use or was to use it because we use any
argument we think of the least important
argument is the technological spin off
in a sense big science is the
technological substitute for war just as
war pushes technology and develops
things which are useful even in times of
peace like microwave ovens which came
out of the radar technology of World War
two in the same way bill going beyond
what we already know in experiments in
fundamental physics pushes technology
one example when physicists first
started to try to accelerate electrons
around and rings they found as could be
understood theoretically that this a lot
of the energy of the electrons was being
drained off in a kind of radiation that
was produced when electrons go round in
circles called synchrotron radiation
this was a nuisance for high-energy
physics because a drained energy away
from the accelerated electrons but the
synchrotron radiation itself turned out
to be very important for studying the
properties of materials and it's a sort
of nice twist that when Berkeley lost
the bevatron that I mentioned earlier
what it has now as a substitute is an
accelerator that is designed to produce
synchotron radiation for practical
purposes of studying materials another
example of technological spin-off is the
world wide web which we all use but it
was invented by physicists at CERN as
the means of sharing data that was
coming out of experiments in elementary
particle
we should also not well but although we
talk about these spin-offs this I don't
think is anywhere near the most
important thing more important is the
long-run discoveries in fundamental
science changed the way we live but it
doesn't happen immediately and to take
an example a little before the end of
the 19th century JJ Thompson in
Cambridge was making fundamental studies
of the way electricity flows and in the
course of these studies he discovered
what it was the first discovered
elementary particle the electron and in
a huge electronics industry could not
exist without the knowledge of the
existence of this particle which carries
electric currents in all ordinary
electric circuits if JJ Thompson in 1897
had been directed to work on practical
problems problems of immediate
technological importance he would have
developed a better steam boiler but he
would not have discovered the electron
and I think another important and this
is less rarely recognized spin-off from
high-energy physics is that it has a
tremendous intellectual attraction and I
see this with students coming into my
university many of them are motivated to
go into science because of the challenge
of discovering fundamental facts about
the way the world is ordered and many of
them become scientists who do things of
great practical importance the society
that decides that it will only support
applied science and not waste money on
pure science is likely to be a society
that will wind up with neither
in the in the long run though I think
perhaps the greatest contribution of
fundamental physics which necessarily is
big science now is as a contribution to
our culture I recently read a remark by
Lytton Strachey who you may know about
is the author of eminent Victorians his
remark was that the modern world began
on July 15 1660 - which was the date of
the formation of the Royal Society
England's great academy of sciences and
in particular the expansion of the
scientific understanding that the world
is governed by impersonal mathematical
laws has left much less room for
religious fanaticism and I think that's
it's not an accident that the country
that countries places like Europe where
the Scientific Revolution began and
countries like the United States and
Japan that have embraced modern science
are the countries where religious
fanaticism has greatly diminished
whereas in other parts of the world it
continues and continues to have its
baleful effects
now I've been talking about physics
because that's what I do and that's what
I know best there are examples of big
science now increasingly also in biology
genome projects and in geology drilling
down to the mantle of the earth I don't
I'm not going to talk about them because
I don't know much about them but I think
probably very similar things could be
said about them the one other area where
I do work is astronomy in a particular
cosmology and by the way I don't
remember what time I started there's 130
okay I'm gonna alright fine then I I
probably have enough time I can speak
faster and faster
astronomy has had a very different
history from physics although it is
wound up in much the same situation
astronomy was supported by government as
big science from very early times and
that's because unlike physics
until recently astronomy was useful
astronomy was useful in the ancient
world for making calendars for telling
time for Direction finding for
navigation and for those who believed in
astrology it was important for
predicting the future and all of those
led to government supports when the
Kingdom of Egypt the Hellenistic kingdom
of Egypt was founded as a fragment of
Alexander the Great's Empire after his
death the first kings of Hellenistic
Egypt founded a scientific Institute in
Alexandria called the museum it was
called the museum because it was
dedicated to the Nine Muses and one of
the muses really took over from her
sisters it was the muse
arania the muse of astronomy and at this
laboratory well I should call it perhaps
an Institute at this
Institute astronomers like Aristarchus
and Eratosthenes worked who between them
measured the size of the Sun the moon
and the earth and the distance of the
Sun and Moon from the earth spectacular
achievement of ancient science and this
government support on a large scale of
research in astronomy continued Khalif
Alma moon founded the House of Wisdom in
Baghdad frederick ii of spain evicted me
of denmark gave a very large grant to a
nobleman Tycho Brahe Hey to build an
observatory you Ronnie Borg on an island
off the coast of Denmark in more recent
times we have the Greenwich Observatory
in England and the US Naval Observatory
in America doing practical astronomy for
navigation and timekeeping and also
doing fundamental research in the 19th
century you have rich people amateurs
who get into the business and do
research themselves for instance the
third Earl of Rosse in his home
observatory built the largest telescope
in the world at the time called he
called it Leviathan and used it to for
example to discover the fact that
nebulae what we now know of as galaxies
have spiral arms and rich men in America
who were not themselves amateur
astronomers nevertheless began to build
observatories and telescopes in in order
to gain respectability and there are
people with names like Yerkes who was
involved in the Chicago streetcar
business we needed respectability and
lick and hooker and then more recently
tech and hobby
but now astronomy is facing tasks that
are way beyond the resources of private
individuals and that strain the
resources of government you have to get
observatories above the Earth's
atmosphere and this is not only because
the Earth's atmosphere blurs images but
also because it blocks radiation of
various wavelengths like x-rays and
infrared radiation which are emitted by
astronomical objects in which we need to
study and we can only do it by getting
outside the atmosphere there have been a
number of these extraterrestrial
observatories that have made this a
golden age of cosmology in particular
for example the Hubble the Hubble Space
Telescope not only makes those beautiful
pictures of nebulae and planets that you
may have seen but together with a bunch
of ground-based observatories has
discovered that the expansion of the
universe which had been thought to be
net must be slowing down because matter
is attracting itself gravitationally and
would tend to hold back an expansion the
expansion instead of speeding up because
of some kind of mysterious dark energy
that pervades all space that we don't
yet understand another satellite that's
less well known but equally exciting
called w map Wilkinson microwave
anisotropy probe is sitting out not just
at low-earth orbit like Hubble but a
million miles from Earth it's actually
in orbit around the Sun rather than
around the earth and it's making
exquisite measurements of the microwave
radiation left over from a time when the
universe was well when the Big Bang was
380,000 years old and we using
measurements of this radiation we can
infer that the Big Bang is 13.7 two
billion years old and actually say this
with a straight face I mean the
uncertainty is like point oh a few
and it also has allowed us to measure
the abundances of various constituents
of the universe like ordinary matter
which is about four percent the dark
matter which is about twenty four
percent and everything else is this
mysterious dark energy so this has been
a tremendously exciting time in fact
cosmology has lately had some of the
excitement that elementary particle
physics used to have and they have again
when the Large Hadron Collider begins to
make its discoveries but it's awfully
expensive so it runs into the same
problem as building accelerators and it
runs into another problem which is
peculiar to astronomy and that is that
extraterrestrial observatories are
funded by the same government agency
that funds something entirely different
manned spaceflight and manned
spaceflight gets much more money than
science does at NASA in fact let me be
perfectly clear the manned spaceflight
program although often sold as a
scientific research program is nothing
of the sort
people all of the Great observatories in
space that have made this such a
wonderful time for astronomy and
cosmology are unmanned and human beings
really play no role in space in this
it's all done by human beings on the
ground in radio links to their
extraterrestrial experiments but science
is receiving much less funding and the
funding is decreases is decreasing this
successor to the Hubble Space Telescope
as and other space telescope called the
James Webb Space Telescope which will
specialize in infrared observations
which is necessary but when you look at
something from very very far away
because of the expansion of the universe
the light is shifted toward the red end
of the spectrum and you have to be able
to study things that infrared
wavelengths which don't penetrate the
Earth's atmosphere this telescope is
scheduled well is intended to go out a
million miles from Earth in the general
neighborhood of where the W map
did I say celery observatory is was
located it is continuing to be funded
but at a level which will guarantee you
will never fly and another program was
identified last year by the astronomical
community working through a committee of
the National Academy of Sciences they
were asked to prioritize research in
astronomy and they had in particular
they identified what they regarded as
the number one priority an infrared
Observatory called W first I don't
remember what it stands for which is
intended among other things to probe the
dark energy which is causing the
expansion of the universe to accelerate
in the budget for a NASA there was no
funds at all for that the top priority
of the astronomers and yet man Space
Flight
fortunately somewhat diminished now
continues as the major part of NASA's
budget I I speak of this with some
feeling in fact I have to think I'm
probably getting to be a bore on this
subject because when the super collider
was canceled it was in competition with
the International Space Station the
International Space Station was sold as
a scientific research laboratory it has
produced nothing of scientific value it
is true that there is just in the latest
endeavor launched there is a laboratory
going up to the International Space
Station to study cosmic rays not for
discovering new kinds of particles but
to study cosmic rays for their own sake
it's it
do for the first time real science
onboard the International Space Station
so you might say that's a counter
example to what I was saying but in fact
it could much more cheaply have been
built to be launched by an unmanned
rocket and its operation whether on an
unmanned Observatory hour on the
International Space Station will not
involve human beings in any way I'm told
that there's a switch which the
astronauts can turn on but that's it as
far as their participation
now unfortunately Congress was very
confused about this issue of the
scientific importance I remember once at
a congressional hearing a congressman
said he could understand how the
International Space Station would help
us to learn about the universe but he
couldn't understand that about the SSC
and I had already testified so I
couldn't say anything so I just sat
there and cried President Clinton felt
that he could only give active support
to one Texas project the International
Space Station was seen as a Texas
project because it was head it was
governed from Houston the manned space
flight center and he decided he would
support the International Space Station
and Congress was very glad to go along
in fact one of the things that gave the
International Space Station an advantage
over the SSC is that it was much more
expensive it has cost about a hundred
billion dollars as compared to what the
SSC would have cost which was about 10
billion dollars and that hundred billion
dollars was cleverly spread by NASA in
contracts over the whole country so that
there were congressmen from many
districts and senators from practically
every state who were active supporters
of the International Space Station well
the big science in the forum I've been
describing it runs into competition not
only from manned space flight of course
or from other brain
inches of science like solid-state
physics or medicine or geology but it
runs into competition with lots of the
other things our society needs
government to adequately support we need
education to be supported at a level so
that a teaching career will be
attractive to the best graduates of our
colleges as it now isn't our passenger
rail infrastructure and our internet
access structure even our bridges are at
a state which look very poor compared to
their counterparts in Europe or East
Asia our patent office is so undermanned
it takes years to get a patent
application approved our judge our
judiciary so under men that it takes
years to get a civil action heard our
prisons are so undermanned that being
incarcerated the Supreme Court recently
decided in some states as amounts to
cruel and unusual punishment violation
of what is it the Eighth Amendment our
ports are insecure to terrorists and
many Americans go without adequate
health care these are all things that
require government support now for each
one of the things I mentioned there are
plenty of advocates just like I'm an
advocate for big science but we tend to
get in each other's way we tend to
conflict with each other
I ran into an example of this I'm almost
finished
a little while ago and and well some
years ago in Texas I found myself
sitting at dinner with a member of the
Appropriations Committee of the Texas
House and she she learned I was a
professor at the University of Texas and
she began to tell me how enthused I was
enthusiastically supporting more funding
for higher education and of course this
wasn't something I minded hearing
and then I stupidly asked her and I'm so
I told her I so glad to hear this what
are you planning as the revenue source
to support this and she blinked at me
and she's oh no I'm not planning to
raise taxes we're gonna take the money
from healthcare this is not what we need
what we need is for those of us who care
about government support for all the
things our society needs to unite to
[ __ ] help shift the balance of our
economy more away from private Goods in
the direction of public goods where the
real needs of our society are the real
needs of our society are not for more
consumer electronics but for education
health cares scientific research and so
on and this means higher taxes which is
a hard sell in a time when a anti-tax
mania has afflicted the American public
but it's only in this way that we can
get adequate funding for all the things
that our society really needs for
education for healthcare for
infrastructure and all the others and
also for science of all sizes thank you
[Applause]
[Music]